bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur TVfil 78 nous sommes le 12
mars c'est dans l'actualité locale
aujourd'hui la CGT yvelinky vient de
désigner la sa nouvelle présidente lors
de son traditionnel congrès avec 8000
adhérents c'est le premier syndicat du
département le droit au logement
opposable depuis 8 ans les mallogés
peuvent faire valoir leurs droits à une
invitation décente une loi qui n'est pas
toujours appliquée selon la Fondation
Abbé Pierre les explications de son
délégué général invité de cette édition
elle d'ici au 22 mars date du premier
tour des départementales nous vous
proposons un focus sur plusieurs cantons
les forces en présence pour pivoter nous
nous arrêterons à Trappes pour débuter
une partie des salariés de la société
Europcar dont le siège social en France
se trouve à Voisins-le-Bretonneux était
en grève ce matin il dénonce la décision
de la direction d'externaliser une
partie des services informatiques
concrètement des sociétés extérieures
seront mandatées et les employés actuels
transférés vers celle-ci et des employés
qui craignent une remise en cas ou en
cause de leurs avantages RTT convention
collective et surtout une précarisation
de leur poste il demande en compensation
un accompagnement pour une formation et
50000 euros d'indemnités
nous ce que nous craignons c'est que une
fois dans la société informatique on
peut nous disperser ça veut dire moi on
peut me muter à l'autre bout
d'Île-de-France on peut aussi me dire et
ben madame vous n'êtes pas assez vous
n'êtes pas suffisamment compétent sur
les nouvelles technologies parce que
nous travaillons ici à Europcar sur un
système qui date qui date des années 90
donc de 93 donc on n'a pas tous pu
suivre l'évolution technologique par
contre on a beaucoup suivi le métier de
Rocard les spécialistes en fait
finalement sur le métier d'Europe car
nous en fait on a on a rien contre de
changer on a rien contre de découvrir
autre chose il faut quand même le dire
ça
est inévitable donc on va pas se battre
contre ça c'est un combat perdu d'avance
par contre nous avons demandé une
compensation financière parce que de
toute façon s'il y aura un manque à
gagner vu qu'on aura plus de
participation
les primes ça sera plus question d'en
parler pour d'autres ça sera l'occasion
de prendre du temps pour se former
puisque nous avons tous donné vraiment
de nous perdre de notre personne pour
s'investir dans cette entreprise
les syndicats qui voient donc dans cette
externalisation le moyen de diminuer la
masse salariale à l'avant l'entrée en
Bourse pardon de la société Europe car
le congrès départemental de la CGT se
tenait cette semaine à Guyancourt trois
jours de débat pour discuter des
orientations des problématiques
concernant les syndiqués le Congrès et
qui s'est conclu aujourd'hui avec
l'élection du bureau exécutif et la
nomination de la nouvelle secrétaire
générale Mélanie poquet et qui est
abston berger
elle est la nouvelle secrétaire général
de l'Union départementale de la CGT
Yvelines Sonia Poro 35 ans a été élu
pour Amanda de trois ans son premier
engagement remonte à 2008 alors qu'elle
est téléconseillère pour un centre
d'appel entre temps j'ai changé de
d'emploi maintenant je travaille dans
une société d'assurance où je suis
toujours téléconseillère
je suis depuis 2009 donc responsable au
niveau de l'Union Locale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est un
territoire important du département son
élection clôture trois jours de
discussion et débat pour les syndiqués
Yves Linois un moyen pour la
Confédération de faire le bilan des
mouvements menés des orientations et des
actions futures on a eu un très bon
congrès avec un nombre important de
délégués une très grande représentation
des diverses emplois statuts entreprises
avec des débats très riches on a lancé
aussi la perspective d'appeler très
fortement dans le département à la
journée de grève du 9 avril contre un
certain nombre de réformes qui mettent
en jeu le code du travail la protection
des salariés la CGT compte plus de 8000
adhérents dans le département elle est
le premier syndicat notamment dans le
secteur de la métallurgie
je reçois en ce 12 mars christophe
Robert le délégué général de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau nous allons
évoquer avec vous la loi DALO depuis
2008 si vous avez effectué une demande
de logement qui n'a pas reçu de
propositions adaptées vous pouvez saisir
une commission de médiation puis exercer
dans certains cas un recours devant le
tribunal administratif au titre du droit
au logement opposable ça c'est sur le
papier ça semble très bien dans la
réalité c'est un peu plus compliqué à
mettre en application ça ne fonctionne
pas tout simplement
non on peut pas dire que ça fonctionne
cette loi elle est censée protéger les
personnes qui parce qu'ils sont dans une
situation de logement
urgentes et dangereuse des personnes qui
sont dans les logements qui sont sans
logement des personnes qui sont menacées
d'expulsion sans solution alternative
des personnes qui sont présentes d'un
enfant handicapé il y a des catégories
comme ça qui sont déclinés peuvent
effectivement faire appel alors
globalement à l'échelle du pays ça
fonctionne pas mal ce droit de recours
en fait qui donne une obligation de
résultats à l'état alors qu'on avait des
politiques qui donnaient des obligations
de moyens en matière de politique du
logement des personnes défavorisées
fonctionne dans pas mal de territoires
mais il se trouve effectivement que là
où on rencontre des difficultés pour
trouver du logement à Bakou ça
fonctionne pas bien au point que des
personnes qui ont attendu 6 mois pour
être reconnues prioritaires dans la
commission que vous évoquiez à l'instant
qui ensuite ont attendu 6 mois qu'on
leur propose un logement après avoir
être reconnu prioritaire et bien on qui
est à peu près 55 000 ménages qui sont
aujourd'hui hors délais c'est-à-dire que
non seulement ils sont dans une
situation difficile et malgré ce droit
de recours aucune solution ne leur a été
proposée sur ces 55 000 ménages qui
restent à reloger il y en a 40 000 qui
sont en Île de France donc on voit bien
que le problème est particulièrement
concentré dans la région francilienne
alors pourquoi ça bloque à ce point-là
je vais juste repréciser que vous avez
organisé une mobilisation justement à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire de cette de
cette loi le 8 mars la semaine dernière
le DALO l'appliquer c'est possible c'est
ce qu'on pouvait lire sur les pancartes
que vous avez brandit devant l'Assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière qu'est-ce
qui bloque aujourd'hui en Île-de-France
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour
débloquer la situation aussi alors tout
dépend de quoi on parle c'est-à-dire que
les outils aujourd'hui mise à
disposition de l'application de cette
loi peuvent être davantage mobilisés
c'est par exemple le contingent
préfectoral de l'État vous savez en fait
l'État a des droites de réservation qui
sont liées à ces financements de la
construction de logements sociaux
Action Logement qui est l'ancien 1%
logement également et là il y a encore
une bonne partie de logement qui
pourrait être mobilisée pour répondre
aux besoins de ses concitoyens donc là
c'est une action forte de l'État qui
doit dire c'est vraiment une injonction
forte c'est à dire que c'est
l'application de la loi personne ne doit
pouvoir s'en dédouaner il faut donc
mobiliser mais plus largement ça soulève
bien sûr des questions majeures de
politique publique dans leur ensemble en
matière de logement or on manque de
logement on n'a pas assez construit le
logement on manque de logement à Bakou
qui correspondent à la capacité
financière de nos concitoyens et puis la
loi DALO c'est aussi une incitation à la
prévention des exclusions par le
logement je m'explique une des
catégories que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui peut recourir dans le droit au DALO
c'est les personnes menacées d'expulsion
locative si on voulait bien mettre en
place dans ce pays une vraie prévention
des expulsions c'est à dire venir en
aide aux personnes au moment elle
rencontre une difficulté une baisse de
pouvoir d'achat une perte d'emploi un
problème de santé plutôt que de voir
accumuler une dette
pendant des années et des années qui va
être difficile de remédier ou de
remonter la pente et bien il existe des
outils il y a des départements qui le
font très bien où on prévient mieux les
expulsions locatives et dans ce cas là
on aura même pas besoin d'aller jusqu'au
DALO et c'était l'effet levier aussi
attendu de cette loi que de dire ça va
nous conduire à remobiliser l'ensemble
de la puissance publique est à
collectivités locales conseils généraux
pour pouvoir enfin apporter une réponse
en matière de logement nos concitoyens
il y a certains maires en Île-de-France
qui évoque aussi la loi DALO comme étant
mal appliquée sa crème ghettoïsation
aussi est-ce que vous partagez cet avis
gros sujet abordé par le Premier
ministre vendredi dernier
oui bien sûr alors oui bien sûr pour
partie du discours c'est à dire que
effectivement parce que l'offre pas cher
de logements notamment de logements
sociaux pas cher elle est souvent dans
les mêmes quartiers dans les mêmes
communes puisque les personnes sont à la
recherche d'une solution de fil en
aiguille dans la recherche de logements
de ces ménages et bien il se trouve
orienté indirectement vers les mêmes
territoires soit des départements
Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple pour
l'Île-de-France soit des quartiers à
l'échelle d'une ville donnée ou d'une
agglomération donnée simplement si je
partage ce diagnostic si on partage ce
diagnostic à la Fondation Abbé Pierre
c'est quelle réponse on a en face en
gros la solution c'est de dire il faut
dans ce cas là plus de logements sociaux
partout ou plus d'offres de logements à
baloyers partout alors que ce qu'a
évoqué le Premier ministre vendredi qui
est extrêmement dangereux c'est de dire
on va plus les loger les catégories
modestes dans les mêmes quartiers
radicalisation
dans les quartiers d'éviter la
ghettoïsation et de permettre une
certaine mixité si le résultat de ça
c'est plutôt que de faire émerger
vraiment une offre de logement un peu
partout mur et parti ce qui est
souhaitable c'est fermer la porte au
seul logement accessible au ménage
modeste ou au ménage pauvre vous créez
du mal de logement donc c'est une
question de temporalité si le premier
ministre dit plutôt que de les mettre
dans les quartiers toujours les mêmes on
concentre les difficultés moi je vais
tout mettre en oeuvre pour leur proposer
des solutions ailleurs dans le parc
privé ou dans le parc social banco si
c'est de dire bah on ferme la porte ça
veut dire tout simplement les personnes
par exemple à la rue néanmoins aussi
aujourd'hui logement concrètement les
construction le bâtiment ne fonctionne
pas bien on recevait le responsable
départemental de la Fédération du
bâtiment il y a pas très longtemps
justement votre place qui nous
expliquait encore aujourd'hui et ça fait
des années et ça va encore être
compliqué les années à venir les
constructions de logements sont
difficiles et c'est un petit peu l'effet
de la crise donc forcément à quel moment
qu'elle levier là aussi employé alors
l'effet de la crise ça s'est accentué
depuis 2008
mais on avait déjà cette difficulté en
tailleur bon ça fait une vingtaine
d'années qu'on construit pas assez par
rapport aux besoins annuels en logements
dans notre pays et c'est très fort en
Île-de-France
là ça concerne des politiques du
logement dans leur ensemble c'est-à-dire
la politique foncière
est-ce qu'on choisit de faire du bureau
ou du logement dans une ville ça
concerne
l'implication de l'État par exemple cela
construction logements sociaux d'un côté
il dit je veux faire 150000 logements
sociaux on en fait en gros 110 115000
mais en même temps on baisse le budget
destiné à la construction de logements
sociaux dans le projet de loi de
finances 2015 de l'État donc le message
aujourd'hui que vous passez avec la
Fondation abcA c'est quoi c'est au-delà
des discours il faut des actes il faut
aujourd'hui changer cette politique qui
est menée il faut être cohérent
effectivement c'est à dire que c'est une
urgence très importante la question du
logement donc construire beaucoup
beaucoup
capté aussi des logements existants des
logements vacants des logements privés
pour les rendre accessibles
financièrement c'est une question de
mobilisation forte des politiques
publiques dans la durée et ça c'est
parce que l'enjeu il est très fort
au-delà du nombre de logements c'est que
derrière le logement se cache la
question de la santé de la scolarisation
des enfants du vivre ensemble à
l'échelle d'un territoire se cache aussi
la capacité d'un ménage une famille
accueillir des personnes à pouvoir vivre
tout simplement et avoir un espace
sécurisant donc si on prend toutes ces
considérations qui tournent autour du
logement au-delà de l'enveloppe donc tel
je pense qu'on devrait pouvoir booster
significativement la politique du
logement merci Christophe Robert d'être
venu sur ce plateau délégué général de
la Fondation Abbé Pierre pour faire le
point autour de cette loi DALO des
aménagements à prévoir et puis au-delà
de ça au-delà de la politique du
logement là la politique du vivre
ensemble comme vous l'avez rappelé parce
que ça dépasse le 4 le cadre du logement
bien sûr on va rester dans la politique
maintenant avec les élections
départementales 21 canton 42 élus dans
les Yvelines comme dans le reste de la
France nous allons désigner ceux qui
vont siéger dans la nouvelle assemblée
départementale focus ce soir sur le
secteur de trap ou se présente 5 listes
anciennement ville canton trap c'était
l'argi pour ce scrutin du 22 mars à deux
autres communes la verrière et longcourt
de commune ont créé à gauche pour une
seule à droite mais une équation pas
aussi simple que cela conseillère
départementale sortante soutenu par le
Parti socialiste Janine Mary se présente
cette fois-ci nouvelle règle sur la
parité oblige avec Alain agent mère
communiste de la verrière mais ce
dernier n'a pas reçu le soutien de sa
formation c'était pas là l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'était la reconnaissance
des qualités de chacun pour pouvoir
porter cette cette fibre sociale
auprès auprès des gens et lui attrape en
tant que premier adjointe à l'éducation
Janine Marie siège au département depuis
2008 principal axe de campagne l'action
sociale c'est un département qui a
suffisamment de richesse pour qu'il
s'interroge sur la répartition de ces
richesses et que une partie de ces
richesses puisse être destinée au
développement et à la réponse aux
besoins qui se sont des besoins soci
éducatif ou d'aménagement ou des besoins
écologiques sur notre canton pour
renverser ce canton et réaliser le Grand
Chelem attendu par le président sortant
du conseil départemental pierre Bédié la
droite mise sur un ticket composé du
maire d'Élancourt Jean-Michel fourgou
c'est de sa deuxième adjointe en charge
de l'éducation Anne Caprio Jean-Michel
fourgousse ancien député qui ne cache
pas sa véléité à retrouver son poste
dans deux ans et qui axe sa campagne sur
le développement économique mais aussi
sur le numérique à l'école prenant pour
exemple les réalisations menées dans sa
ville moi mon boulot jusqu'à maintenant
sur Élancourt des luttes terrain avec
les familles et les enseignants ils nous
permettent aujourd'hui de de transmettre
cette expérience là aux autres villes du
département et également notre objectif
est aussi de faire un lien entre la
pédagogie et les apprentissages
scolaires entre le primaire et le
secondaire puisque le Conseil général a
bien sûr la compétence des collèges
l'oncle et ce canton donc vont
un exemple national avec bien sûr la
zone de Saint-Quentin de cette évolution
de la pédagogie française qui vous le
savez trop frontale trop magistral il
faut que l'enfant demain soit beaucoup
plus indépendant qu'il qu'il soit plus
impliqué dans l'apprentissage on est en
train de transformer les méthodes
d'apprentissage reste qu'une troisième
liste pourrait bien venir perturber ce
duel gauche droite Nicolas Bauer et
ludoposition à Élancourt et Maribo qui
se présentent sous les couleurs de
Marine Le Pen et on tente bien surfer
sur les derniers sondages nationaux nous
on alerte nos compatriotes sur leur
incapacité à gouverner notre pays nous
on offre une alternative qui je crois
aujourd'hui est crédible on l'a montré
dans les conseils municipaux on est
extrêmement
comment dire on est extrêmement
percutant on essaie de l'être en tout
cas on est parfois un peu seul contre
tous je crois que que les Français s'en
attente de quelque chose de fort qui
n'arrive pas et je pense que ça sera
cette cette élection départementale sera
forcément national dans ces deux cantons
deux autres listes se présentent l'une
portée par Esther Lafitte et Luc
miserait au nom du Front de gauche et
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts l'autre
associe Slimane busana et Karima la
Suède sans étiquette
je vous retrouve demain vendredi pour
une nouvelle édition du journal nous
ferons un point complet sur l'actualité
du jour et puis bien sûr l'essentiel de
la semaine je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée